we're seeing a big gap between different
countries and their position on covid in
China at the moment China is seeing a
big surge by some assessments tens of
millions of cases each day we've seen
America and Italy now insist on testing
for travelers coming from China and yet
you have the UK saying that they will
not be reintroducing testing or
intensifying any restrictions at this
stage of course things could change in
the days the weeks to come we've seen
some Asian countries like Japan are
putting a cap on the number of Travelers
coming through and some of the data that
the likes of Italy is seeing is
concerning they've looked at some
post-christmas flights and around half
of some of those coming in from China
into an airport in Milan a testing
positive for covid-19 so there is a
worry that this could spread rapidly
internationally but China has brought an
end to its zero covert policy it is Keen
to allow its citizens to travel and it
doesn't look to be curbing that at the
moment it says that any criticism of its
policy is merely a smear campaign
politically motivated and biased